esto que he dibujado aquí es el cerebro
humano y esto es lo que verías si
estuvieras mirando a alguien y estuviera
parado de perfil o si estuviera frente a
ti y parado de lado entonces esto sería
el frente de su cabeza y sus ojos su
nariz y su boca se encontrarían aquí
abajo esto sería la parte posterior de
su cabeza y esto sería la parte superior
por acá abajo está la parte inferior y
nos referimos a esta área esta área
grande de aquí que es lo primero que
verías si solo miradas la parte externa
del cerebro y la llamamos corteza
cerebral
podrías notar enseguida algo acerca de
la corteza cerebral y es que se ve un
poco arrugada y en realidad lo está en
lugar de tener una superficie lisa
realmente tiene muchas protuberancias y
pliegues y esto es sumamente útil porque
permite que la corteza cerebral tenga
mayor área de superficie le permite
tener espacio para más neuronas le da
una mayor masa celular
generalmente dividimos la corteza
cerebral en cuatro hemisferios el
primero es el lóbulo frontal que estoy
sembrando en azul aquí
y la siguiente área es el lóbulo
parietal que está acá atrás hacia arriba
y hacia la parte posterior también
tenemos el lóbulo occipital que voy a
colorear en rosa y finalmente tenemos el
lóbulo temporal que dibujaré en violeta
acá el lóbulo frontal se conforma de dos
regiones principales estas incluyen la
franja motora o corteza motora así como
la corteza prefrontal la corteza o
franja motora es responsable de los
movimientos de nuestro cuerpo de hecho
si pudieras retirar el cráneo de una
persona y estimular eléctricamente
distintas áreas de la corteza motora
podrías hacer que la mano de esa persona
se contrajera o que su pierna se moviera
solo estimulando esa área en su cerebro
el lóbulo frontal también contiene la
corteza prefrontal que es la parte del
cerebro que se encarga de lo que
llamamos funciones ejecutivas cosas como
pensar y resolver problemas tienen lugar
en la corteza prefrontal no sólo eso
sino también ayuda a supervisar y
dirigir todas
las demás áreas de nuestro cerebro otra
parte del lóbulo frontal que merece
mención se conoce como el área de broca
que es una parte del cerebro que se
asocia con el habla vayamos a esta parte
amarillo anaranjada aquí que dijimos que
es el lóbulo parietal esta parte de la
corteza cerebral también es importante
para realizar una cantidad de tareas
diferentes una parte importante del
lóbulo parietal es la corteza
somatosensorial
y esta es la parte de tu cerebro que se
asocia con las sensaciones y no me
refiero a la sensación emocional lo que
quiero decir es que esta es la parte del
cerebro que recibe información de todo
tu cuerpo sobre tacto y presión
temperatura y dolor así la corteza
motora nos ayuda a extender el brazo y a
tomar una taza de café pero la corteza
somatosensorial es lo que nos permitiría
sentir la presión de esa taza de café o
decirnos qué tan caliente está podrías
estar pensando que estas dos cosas
parecen estar íntimamente relacionadas y
lo están de hecho aunque decimos que se
localizan en diferentes lóbulos del
cerebro en realidad están una junto a la
otra entonces este lado del cerebro
hacia este lado de la hendidura dentro
del lóbulo frontal es la corteza motora
y justo a un lado en la parte parietal y
hacia atrás está la corteza
somatosensorial y juntas se pueden
considerar como la corteza sensorial
motora
nuestro lóbulo parietal también es
responsable del procesamiento espacial o
la manipulación espacial con esto quiero
decir que ayuda a que te oriente en el
espacio tridimensional pero esta parte
del cerebro no solo nos ayuda a entender
dónde estamos en el espacio sino que nos
ayuda a entender el espacio que nos
rodea de manera más general por ejemplo
si quiero extender el brazo y tomar una
taza de café que está frente a mí puedo
usar mi corteza prefrontal para plantear
el movimiento y me corta esa motora para
completar el movimiento pero también
necesito mi corteza parietal para que me
diga dónde está esa taza de café frente
a mí y sin eso no podría estirar el
brazo y tomar las otras cosas como saber
andar por tu casa o ciudad también es a
lo que nos referimos cuando hablamos de
la manipulación o procesamiento espacial
nuestro lóbulo occipital
que está en la parte de atrás de nuestro
cerebro se encarga de las cosas
relacionadas con la visión podemos ver
con nuestros ojos que están en la parte
de enfrente de nuestra cabeza pero
después de recopilar esa información del
mundo que nos rodea esa información en
realidad se va hasta la parte de atrás
de nuestro cerebro para que se procese
entonces pongamos la visión aquí otro
término que podrías escuchar en relación
con el lóbulo occipital es corteza
estriado y esto se refiere simplemente
al hecho de que si miras el lóbulo
occipital bajo el microscopio y si ves
esas células parecerían tener rayas o
estar estriadas el último lóbulo del
cerebro es la corteza temporal y está en
color violeta esta parte del cerebro se
encarga del procesamiento auditivo como
sucedió con la visión de nuestro lóbulo
occipital la información entra a través
de nuestros oídos pero se procesa en
nuestro cerebro en la corteza temporal
otra área importante en la corteza
temporal es lo que se conoce como el
área de ware nicky cuando
de la corteza frontal hablamos del área
de broca que dijimos era responsable del
habla bien pues el área de bernie que se
encarga de la percepción del lenguaje y
su comprensión antes de que termine este
vídeo sólo quiero tomar un momento para
señalar que los distintos lóbulos del
cerebro hacen mucho más que solo las
cosas que he mencionado aquí sin embargo
en general estas son las cosas en las
que debes pensar cuando pienses en los
diferentes lóbulos del cerebro